hey everyone at senior reviews editor
Peter Brown standing in for reviewer
Miguel concepción to tell you about
Yakuza 5 diving back into Japan's
criminal underworld with series mainstay
Kazuma Kiryu as its narrative anchor is
like jumping into another season of a
well received cable TV drama usually
doesn't take 8 years for a show to reach
its fifth season but we'll take this
over not getting Yakuza 5 at all it even
manages to be more feature-rich than
Yakuza 4 thanks to a robust suite of
minigames and countless street fights
spread across multiple urban districts
as effective as Kazuma can be as a solo
protagonist having four other playable
characters each with their own robust
storylines adds immense value to Yakuza
5 their journeys are personal with plot
threads that intertwine like a Tarantino
film and converge at the end like a
narrative Voltron Kazuma kicks off
Yakuza 5 on an intriguing note disguised
as a taxi driver who's making a modest
living in Fukuoka unsurprisingly this
occupation gave Sega an excuse to make
driving an important part of the game
overall there's enough taxi based
gameplay to divert you from the story
for hours when you have a fare you're
expected to adhere to strict rules of
the road on the flip side you can let
loose on the highway with high speed
races where you can execute special
moves inspired by Yakuza fives combat
there aren't any severe progression
barriers to stop you from mainlining the
story though you would have to maintain
a strong sense of focus to ignore Yakuza
fives seemingly countless and
tantalizing minigames some of which have
the same level of depth as taxi driver
to add further variety the plot of
ex-con Tyga Sai Jima temporarily takes
the game out of the concrete jungles of
Tokyo and into the snowy forests this
leads to a surprisingly engrossing
hunting minigame stocking prey without
startling them demands a high level of
patience and precision especially since
the intensity of snowfall fluctuates
frequently Yakuza fives thorough
tutorials make its time-tested gameplay
accessible for newcomers but its
storylines bring with it four games
worth of emotional baggage and gravitas
nothing in Yakuza 5 underscores the
series passage of time more than Haruka
Salim Laura's story arc for continued
and consistent relevance in the series
serves as one of the many rewards to
fans who have followed Yakuza since the
first game the fact that Yakuza 5 marks
the first time Haruka is a playable
character as you know woo
although the significance may be lost to
first timers in Yakuza fives world
there's only one career path for a
Japanese teenage girl like Haruka that
of a pop idol given the series history
with rhythm based gameplay mostly in the
form of karaoke this chapter makes for a
compelling and amusing break from
walking in the shoes of a gangster
beyond the dance studio practices there
are comedy skits TV show appearances and
even dance offs in the streets
one amusingly creepy minigame is a
meet-and-greet handshake session where
you have to please each attending fan as
long as you can without attracting the
security guard who is there to keep the
line moving
just don't expect harakas road to
success to be as smoothly rival idols
and conflicts with competing management
companies provide more than enough drama
for this one chapter the core combat in
Yakuza 5 has remained mostly unchanged
since the first game and it's a credit
to this series that hasn't gotten stale
yet fans will immediately recognize
kazuma's fighting animations throws
dodges and opportunities to learn new
moves ensure that combat isn't
one-dimensional smashing a thugs face on
the side of a building never gets old
it always looks brutal but more
importantly it offers a gratifying sense
of finality as much as you can mash your
way to victory with quick attacks these
deadlier moves are doubly effective in
scaring off other gangsters turning a
60-second brawl into a 15 second beating
despite being similar to previous games
yeah cos of 5s combat serves the game
very well
while playing previous lockers of games
isn't a prerequisite loyal fans who have
followed the series up to this point
will feel rewarded with every throwback
whether it's a return of a supporting
character or a revisit to a ramen shop
that has remained in business for
multiple games even if melee combat
lacks the sophistication of Batman
Arkham games or the Assassin's Creed
franchise yuccas f5 makes up for its
modest shortcomings with enthralling
diversions and eye-popping settings that
compel one to look at travel deals to
Japan
the year he will allow you to theory
Tigger Yuki